what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
I don't know morning night coffee
thoughts
um I see my clippers texting me
yes you can clip re-clip that now today
I will be talking about
how women lie
how how people lie okay now this is not
about any specific situation
um that's what my lawyers told me to say
um I'm also going to be getting ready to
shoot and I'll show you how bad I am at
makeup because I'm like actually
horrible
so so the difference okay I had a
ex-friend and I really haven't talked
and talked about this
because because
here's the problem okay this is what
happens I want to tell you guys stories
about my life
that I should be entitled to tell
now the problem is then the people in
those stories will Stitch it and be like
well I was this story
ah
so I trapped just you know makeup wise I
try to cover up my under eyes okay
now
then then you get into this problem
where it like becomes clout chasing and
even if you don't say no one would know
who it is but those anyways okay
so the way but what I learned from this
was this friend came forward made this
whole video about me
saying I'm fake I'm from her point of
view she thinks that maybe my opinions
are fake okay
and that this just changed all of a
sudden but remember before the internet
we had different types of relationships
you could talk you could know someone
for years
for years and you wouldn't know if
they're conservative if they're Democrat
like what their opinions are on certain
things
now it becomes unfortunate as a content
creator because the bigger you get
the more you share and the more people
can find opinions that you disagree with
this leads to family and friends being
mad at you for your opinions now before
you still had those opinions B just
never spoke about them so this friend
this friend okay
she she what did she do
she was a raging feminist
so mind you why would I go out of my way
to tell this [__] sorry this woman I
shouldn't call her [__] okay
my opinions
like lady
at like this is the same girl that got
mad at me for not posting a black Square
and I wasn't even on Instagram like that
I was just minding my business going to
work you know I was working my sales
copier job and this girl is like why
haven't you posted a black Square now
mind you guys I've never kept it a
secret that I'm conservative
and this is another thing everyone comes
out is she pivoting is she grifting
pivoting into the conservative Niche
guys
I've been conservative I've had pro-life
I think I've done a pro-life like
anti-abortion
episode like you're talking to the girl
that wore a sign that said abortion is a
cop-out
isn't that a conservative position
okay
okay okay okay okay
now so from this so it's interesting
because again the way women lie is they
say things that they don't know as fact
so this girl comes forward and she's
like well she didn't have these opinions
before but what she didn't realize
is that
she was
one one
she was so crazy to be around and so
engulfed in her like liberal stuff
that I didn't really want to tell her
those opinions like why would I why
would I if I'm friends with someone
right why would I go out of my way to
give them an opinion on something if
that's not what we do and I know they're
stuck in that like that's what they're
gonna think and you know I I personally
could be friends with people that
disagree now liberals it is not the same
boy boy I'm gonna take you guys with me
because I need I need the rest of my
makeup stuff but
okay so so
then you know she goes on on Tick Tock
or YouTube says this is a matter of fact
this is a matter of fact and everyone
takes her word as a matter of fact
because she knew me for so long so
therefore
now
now that's the thing about the Liberals
is they don't realize how unpleasant
they are to be around
now it doesn't mean all the time but
when it comes to like where the heck is
my my makeup piece when it comes to like
political stuff
like they don't realize
that they're so unpleasant to be around
and they can't handle different opinions
that nobody tells them
their real opinion so then then these
girls would come forward and be like she
was so cool before she was so nice like
she wasn't like this well lady
thank you for vouching that I'm a nice
person and I've always been polite thank
you I appreciate that
um I still can't find this makeup piece
but sorry but
[Music]
I've you know some opinions have changed
sure
but overall I've always been consistent
I've always been conservative
and I've always had more you know
traditionally anyways everyone is this
that's how women lie is they say things
that they don't know as fact
now there's another you know situation I
was in oh Jesus
and the problem is
people will hear parts of the truth but
not understand the whole truth
and not think of things from the 360
point of view
and the problem with the Internet is now
it becomes profitable
to expose me
and the other problem is there's
and I'm gonna do a whole video on this
but these other content creators are so
gung-ho
like they make money off of spreading
[__] about me so it's like
they'll they'll be partially true right
where the ex-friend comes in and says
well she didn't think like this before
and
partially true right partially like
maybe I didn't I wasn't as loud about my
opinions before because I was playing
volleyballs working a sales job what
incentive do I have to give my opinions
to a girl I know is kind of crazy
but the reaction channels sorry there's
a helicopter flying don't know this
context and nor do they care to find out
and
then then
yeah so that's the issue we get into
here and
she also made up some stuff like I'll
give you an example this girl also said
she said
she that I never lived with a guy and I
was like
I could show you the lease
I could show you the well sort of right
he lived it it's a long story it's a
long story but but
partially true right it was for a short
time period
but
whatever but you know
and it's funny
because this person's family even calls
this girl a liar and I'm like I've known
this girl forever she
no I'm not I'm not even trying to
because what I don't want to do is go
back and forth with uh but it's hard
because you don't want to go back and
forth with these people but at the same
time you want to defend yourself because
they're spreading lies
now
let me ask blessing I'm gonna
I'm kidding
um
overall Road good brand sorry guys I'm
distracted but
then okay so this is how bad I am at
makeup if any of the girlies watching
this want to help me all I do is I put
some [__] under my eyes
and then I throw on a palette and just
you know
but yeah so this is the problem women
lie with a bit of Truth or they'll be a
little bit of Truth
a bunch of likes with it and the
reaction channels are so bloodthirsty
that they don't even care what's true
and what's false that's what
so you know
freaking but that's the hard thing that
I've learned in this becoming so
successful so fast because a lot of
people don't realize how quick
everything hit
and it was okay it wasn't overnight
overnight because when I want to get
good at something I get obsessed with it
and this is how I was with volleyball
for years
I I played Semi-Pro volleyball I want to
go pro and that was all I cared about
and I spent like four or five hours a
day playing volleyball I loved it and
for YouTube I spent like a year and a
half making zero dollars well I mean
here and there right but like roughly
like less than less than 30 000 a year
okay I have no idea what I made but it
was nothing
two
blowing up fast and employing like 20
people
now
this comes with a lot of problems now a
lot of problems that personally I did
not anticipate how could one anticipate
friends of years stopping being friends
with me because of opinions that they
don't have to watch online how would one
anticipate that okay
how would one anticipate
people
that you're friends with making videos
about you calling you this this and this
how does one now maybe from the outside
looking in you're thinking Pearl
that would have been an easy thing to
spot but
let me tell you
outside looking in
it was not anyway
but that's the thing when women lie
women tell a little bit of Truth and
then tell 10 lies until 10 lies or or
this isn't just a woman thing when
people lie they'll make an assumption
they'll have a little beast piece of
information and then make a roundabout
assumption
and quite frankly quite frankly
these people are crazy
and they're just looking for clout
looking for money
and it's unfortunate because a lot of
the people like the girl that made that
video about me
I could list so many nice things that my
family's done for her over the years
like we gave her housing in the Summers
for free
we I remember one time I took a test for
her in college
I just did it like you know I'm sorry I
admitted to cheating okay I'm sorry I'm
sorry
um
I've learned her money on like multiple
occasions
but the second that it's profitable
for her to
make a career off of me
um or you know money whatever clout
whatever she does it and it's
unfortunate but you know
hey living you learn and the the great
thing about all this is I see who the
real people are and who is fake and also
my dog is snoring and at least now
I know
so
you know at the end of the day it's
really their loss because
I'm a good friend and anyone the the
funny thing is everyone that's come
forward with stories or whatever none of
them can say I'm not a good friend and
none of them can say I was a mean person
they could just say she said something
dumb that was it that's really all they
got on me so you know all right okay
anyways guys
um I'm gonna finish
my makeup
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and if you have
any like
makeup tips please help me because I
don't understand
um and I'll talk to you guys next time